(dramatic music)
(Javelin roaring)
- [Narrator] This is the Javelin,
an American made missile launcher
that has been critical
for Ukrainian forces
in repelling the Russians.
The Javelin's efficacy,
especially against tanks
has made it a symbol of the resistance.
- There's even a story
about Ukrainian parents
naming their children, not a joke,
they're newborn child Javelin or Javelina.
- [Narrator] The US has already committed
8,500 Javelins to Ukraine.
Last year, President Biden
ordered an additional
$653 million worth of Javelins to be sent
to aid in the war effort.
But Raytheon and Lockheed Martin
the two primary defense
contractors that make the Javelin
said that most of what's pledged
from the US is existing
stocks, not new production,
and that doubling production
wouldn't be possible until 2026.
- There is no magic formula
in the supply chain to accelerate this.
- [Narrator] The inability
of US defense contractors
to quickly replenish
weaponry has raised questions
about the capability of
America's Defense Industry
and led some Pentagon officials to argue
that industry consolidation
has gone too far.
- The challenges with the
Javelin are a wake up call.
- Ukraine has shown that
our approach to acquisition
since the end of the Cold
War has got a downside.
(Javelin whooshing)
- The Javelin and Stinger
missile has become
the poster child for both
the effects of consolidation
and indeed the effects
of supply chain problems.
- [Narrator] In 2021, the US spent
roughly $800 billion on its defense.
That's more than China, India,
the United Kingdom,
Russia, France, Germany,
Saudi Arabia, Japan and
South Korea combined.
Given the astonishing
amount America spends
on its Defense Industry
why can't the US arm
the Ukrainians faster?
The answer lies partially
in how America procures its weapons.
This graph charts the
consolidation that's taken place
within the defense sector.
In the early 1990s, the US
relied on 51 primary contractors.
Today that number is just five.
Lockheed Martin, Boeing, Raytheon,
Northrop Grumman and General Dynamics.
- The fundamental reason
that defense companies
decided to consolidate
after the Cold War was that
department told them to do so.
The department was going to be downsizing
in terms of troops and equipment
so therefore there was
a need for them to merge
to address that declining market.
- There was not a major competition
with a great power the
way the US had faced
with the Soviet Union.
So in that sense, if we take
ship building for example
there was a less of a
need to build major ships.
- [Narrator] This trend of consolidation
took place throughout the industry.
Tactical missile suppliers
declined from 13 to 3.
Fixed wing aircraft suppliers declined
from eight to three.
Satellite suppliers have
halved from eight to four
and builders of surface ships
has dropped from eight to two.
- The market in the
defense industrial base
is very different from the
commercial marketplace.
The difference is, is that the government
is both the customer and the
regulator, but it's much harder
than a commercial
marketplace where you have
a virtually unlimited market.
- [Narrator] According
to a 2022 DoD report,
consolidation has left the US reliant
on a small number of contractors
which has stifled innovation
and undermined price competition.
- A lot of contracts, maybe as many
as 40% of DoD contracts
are in fact sole source.
That's either because there
isn't another competitor or
because the existing
manufacturer is just an incumbent
and is such advantages because
they've been doing it so
long that there's not really
another viable competitor.
(Javelin whooshing)
- [Narrator] The Javelin
is a case in point.
- Rocket motors, which are
used in Javelin missiles
there's only really two producers
of those motors, those
engines, Aerojet Rocketdyne
and now of Northrop Grumman,
there used to be five,
six suppliers and now you're down to two.
And obviously if something
goes wrong at one of them
then that puts a lot
of burden on the other
and it just slows down the entire chain.
(machine whirring)
- [Narrator] Ramping up Javelin production
is also difficult
because of the just in time supply chain.
- Scaling up production for
the Javelin is a challenge
and it's a challenge
because the way we procure
and the way we produce the the
Javelin, there are many kind
of single and sole source
suppliers for a lot
of these components.
The companies that produce
these, they produce them
for a specific contract
need, and producing more
than that is not optimal
from a business sense.
- The supply chain challenges
in part because of Covid
has slowed everything down.
So it's actually what
it's done is it's extended
the time it takes on
average to produce systems
in some cases to two, three years.
- [Narrator] A 2023 CSIS report found
that the US is dangerously unprepared
for a major conflict
such as a war with China
in the Taiwan Strait.
- The reality is that in a
war, according to our war games
and many that have been done within
the Department of Defense, both
classified and unclassified,
the US runs out of key munitions
like long range precision strike
in less than a week of a
Taiwan Strait conflict.
The problem is we don't have
enough, not of everything,
but of some very specific weapon
systems that are important
for the kinds of conflicts
that we're likely to face
with China and that are important to
deter those conflicts from even happening.
- [Narrator] Today, many
of the defense sector's
supply chains were built
to fight the war on terror.
- In terms of acquisitions,
the US focused on
components that were important
to target the Islamic State
or the Taliban or
Al-Qaeda around the globe.
Some very specific weapon
systems like drones
and didn't require the kinds of stockpiles
of munitions that are important
for a conventional war.
The Ukraine war was a very stark reminder
that a conventional war is
a war of industrial bases.
Countries involved in a
conventional war, they churned
through munitions, they
churn through weapon systems
at a much more rapid pace than we had seen
during the counter-terrorism
campaigns after 9/11.
- [Narrator] In response
to a request for comment,
Raytheon wrote our industry
has experienced unprecedented
supply chain challenges
over the past two years.
However, by leveraging our scale
we have been able to
provide significant support
to our suppliers, and we're
already seeing some components
like chips and electronics
become more readily available.
(Javelin whooshing)
Which brings us back to the Javelin
and a proposed merger of two contractors.
Aerojet Rocketyne which makes
Javelin motors and L3Harris.
- L3Harris and Aerojet,
which has agreed to the deal.
Both argue that by
combining and being part
of a bigger company that
Aerojet can access resources,
access extra investment
which will help it
perhaps catch up quicker.
- [Narrator] But some politicians,
like Senator Elizabeth Warren disagree.
In a tweet earlier this year
she took aim at the proposed
$4.7 billion merger,
arguing that further consolidation
would undermine competitiveness
within the sector.
(Javelin whooshes)
(soldiers cheering)
It's unclear if the Aerojet
Rocketdyne-L3Harris deal
will go through
especially given that a year ago,
the Federal Trade Commission torpedoed
Lockheed Martin's attempt to
purchase Aerojet Rocketdyne
on antitrust grounds.
- Lockheed accounted
for just about a third
of Aerojet's sales, that
was turned down ultimately
by federal antitrust regulators.
They just basically didn't trust
that Lockheed would
continue to make things
for other people and not just for itself.
L3Harris is different.
It's a very tiny customer
of Aerojet at the moment
and it'll be moving
into areas like missiles
where it's currently just not present.
So it would in theory, emerge
as a stronger competitor
to Lockheed Martin and Northrop Grumman.
(missiles whooshing)
- [Narrator] As war continues in Ukraine
and the threat of other
conflicts around the world loom,
policy makers must now
grapple with constraints
of consolidation and a supply chain built
for yesterday's threat environment.
(Javelin whooshing)